hola a todos cómo están bienvenidos los
profesores de méxico y toda la audiencia
que nos está acompañando el día de hoy
mi nombre es leonor y soy parte del
equipo de khan academy en mexico es con
mucho gusto y alegría que estamos
presentando por primera vez en méxico el
campeonato de canadevi este ahorita les
voy a platicar un poquito de qué se
trata y también aprovecho para invitar a
patir para ti garcía que es parte de
detective en mexico para que nos les
mando un saludo y les hable un poquito
de ella para ti podrían decirnos un poco
qué es lo que estás haciendo aquí en
méxico con el textil por favor hola hola
a todos este mi nombre es para ti y
garcía patricia garcía yo trabajo para
el textil que es una red global de
educadores que nos dedicamos a entrenar
ya capacitar a otros educadores en
méxico y en otros lugares del mundo en
esta ocasión estamos apoyando a khan
academy para poder capacitar a los
maestros en méxico
en perú y en eeuu gracias leonor muchas
gracias
pues empecemos este el día de hoy por
primera vez en méxico estamos
presentando el programa que se llama
campeonato es un programa de canacar
demi que se ha lanzado con muchísimo
éxito en estados unidos y en brasil
atrayendo muchísimos alumnos y docentes
en este caso se va a correr en méxico
durante 10 semanas es un programa en el
cual los profesores van a poder usar el
contenido de tan academy todo el
contenido de matemáticas y ciencias
biología química física ciencia
computacional todo este contenido lo van
a poder utilizar para que sus alumnos
repasen después de el inicio a clases
que siempre es como puedes estarlos
jalando no a los alumnos a que inicien
como cómo hacerlo pues con un programa
divertido con un reto en el cual ellos
van a poder
ganar premios virtuales y medallas y a
la vez también vamos a tener un
contenido muy especial que se llama
actividades de mentalidad de crecimiento
que ahorita explicaré un poco el
concepto y de qué se tratan estas
actividades porque es un concepto
relativamente nuevo en méjico y queremos
que los profesores lo aprovechen al
máximo no cabe resaltar que este
programa es 100% online y gratuito y los
profesores van a poder aprovechar de
este programa desde que arranquemos que
es el 10 de septiembre hasta el 16 de
noviembre
un poquito del contexto pues este
programa como les comentaba inicio en
eeuu se llama néstor o la tormenta de
aprendizaje del año pasado
cuando la lanzaron participan casi un
billón de estudiantes en eeuu y el
objetivo era que participaran 500 mil
entonces nos damos cuenta que es algo
que los profesores quieren que es algo
los alumnos s pues desisten emocionados
y están esperando de parte de canal acá
de mi cada año entonces aquí unas
cuantas cifras 55 por ciento a los
participantes pues venían de escuelas
públicas 65% de ellos eran nuevos
participantes 35 por ciento de ellos
pues ya habían participado en otras
ediciones ellerston que se inició en
2015 y la casi la mayoría bueno al 37
por ciento viene de bachillerato el 25
de secundaria y el 32% de primaria
ahora las preguntas claves de que se
están preguntando tal vez ustedes
después cuando me puedo inscribir te
puedes inscribir a partir del lunes 13
de agosto y las inscripciones nos vamos
a dejar abiertas todo el tiempo porque
porque un profesor tiene que arreglar su
clase saber cómo va con tus grupos va a
tener cuántos alumnos bad inéditos no
queremos que pulsar sienta que esto es
como una presión más que va a tener para
el inicio clases al contrario que sea
algo que le va a ofrecer a sus alumnos
nos va a motivar con tuzsa partidos
entre seamos agosto el profesor puede y
inscribirse al programa y a partir del
10 de septiembre va a poder aprovechar
de pues de todo lo que tiene el programa
que ahorita les voy a comentar un
poquito cómo funciona la dinámica del
programa en donde pues cualquier
profesor de la república mexicana o
estudiante de la república mexicana va a
poder participar no importa si es de
primaria o secundaria donde bachillerato
quién va a poder participar el perdón
que te interrumpa pero no estamos viendo
la presentación es también la
presentación no los está viendo más que
luego de khan academy y entonces
hangouts claro que sí muchas gracias
para ti
de nada
vamos a hacer
voy a compartirles mi pantalla
ahora sí ya lo están viendo
perfectos ahora sí perfecto quien pues
cualquier parte este estudiante sin
importar en qué escuela ésta sí es una
escuela pública es una escuela privada
este nosotros nos adaptamos a todo tipo
de ambiente a todo tipo de out hola
vespertino matutino a cualquier tipo de
ambiente escolar con los profesores van
a poder participar y se les mostramos un
poquito de las dos leyes anteriores
y este es el programa
esto es un poco los datos que les había
comentado antes
y los principios del programa para que
tengan un poquito porque hicimos un
programa así pues hicimos un programa
porque uno méxico este es el número uno
en usuarios en latinoamérica en caracas
de vista muy orgullosos de los docentes
mexicanos que están inspirados en puedes
implementar nuevos métodos y estrategias
en su clase para motivar a sus alumnos y
sabemos que les gusta el contenido
porque pues si no no hubiera tantos
usuarios entonces el programa y los
principios del programa es que es para
todos no es un concurso como tal este lo
consideramos como un reto para cada
alumno para cada grupo este las escuelas
no van a competir entre ellas visualizar
nueva filosofía del programa la
filosofía del programa es que participen
todos y que este programa motive el
aprendizaje motiva la confianza de los
alumnos en la pérdida y seguir
aprendiendo
sientan que las matemáticas y las
ciencias son materias relevantes y este
tengan que ver con su vida real estén
aterrizados a una estera con ejemplos de
su vida real entonces cómo vamos a hacer
que alarmantes y las ciencias sean pues
atractivas para nuestros alumnos
entonces este pues con todo el contenido
de khan academy que estamos
desarrollando y esta campaña sentimos
que vamos a poder lograr inspirar a
nuestros alumnos cómo vamos a empoderar
a los maestros pues les vamos a mostrar
lo fácil que es inscribirte y asignar
tareas y actividades creo que una de las
cosas que muchas personas tal vez nuevas
que nos están escuchando tengan ese
miedo qué tan difícil o cuánto tiempo
voy a pasar este pues buscando asignando
tareas no se preocupen por eso es
literal con unos cuantos clics con los
cuales van a poder ustedes asignar
ejercicios de pruebas calificar todos
estos temas que ellos toman mucho tiempo
como a esto
pues van a poder ustedes enfocarse en su
materia lo que les gusta y usted sabe
muy bien lo que motiva o desmotiva a sus
alumnos lo que queremos es que ustedes
en este regreso a clases sean el héroe
el profesor que llegará con nuevas
propuestas para los alumnos y que los
motiven no queremos que el concurso
también sea justo este reto es de este
programa de 10 semanas pues se promueva
en cualquier entorno escolar que todo el
mundo pueda participar por eso estamos
diciendo alumnos desde primaria hasta
bachillerato de cualquier escuela
privada o pública y que sea divertido no
esté como vamos a hacer que el
aprendizaje sea divertido cómo vamos a
hacer que se motivan los estudiantes
pues haciendo que los alumnos participen
en dinámicas en las cuales ellos mismos
puedan ver su progreso pero también son
parte de una comunidad y uso de clase y
se motivan entre ellos dos es integrar
estos momentos estos elementos de
sorpresa y de premios en el salón de
clases
entonces ustedes estarán preguntando
cómo participar si soy un profesor pues
es muy fácil lo que tiene que ser el
profesor esto lo pueden hacer desde
ámbito es abrir su cuenta en can academy
y una vez que empecemos las
inscripciones lo que van a poder hacer
ustedes es
inscribirse algo a ganar el campeonato y
después agregar a sus alumnos a las
clases conforme vayan agregando clases
ustedes van a poder ir asignando tareas
ejercicios vídeos lo que ustedes más se
consideren pertinentes para su clase y
si un alumno lee un artículo ve un vídeo
eso cuenta como puntos para avanzar en
el en el reto y los profesores van a
poder usar las herramientas de khan
academy para asignar actividades y
práctica personalizada qué quiere decir
esto que también ahorita para ti les va
a mostrar un poquito cómo es la
plataforma pero ustedes van a poder
dividir a sus alumnos en grupos sucede
mucho que todos tenemos distintas
maneras de aprender y es bien difícil
encontrar ejercicios adecuados para cada
una de las necesidades de nuestros
alumnos a veces tenemos salones de clase
de más de 30 alumnos o tenemos varios
grupos y es extremadamente difícil
entender qué es lo que está sucediendo
en la cabeza de cada uno de esos 30
personas no entonces qué pasa cuando tú
tienes una herramienta que te permite
precisamente dividir en grupos y asignar
práctica personalizada adecuada a las
necesidades de cada uno de tus alumnos
pues es mucho más fácil entender lo que
está sucediendo en tu salón de clases
entonces el profesor va a poder recibir
datos e información sobre sus
estudiantes y así ir midiendo el
progreso para poder avanzar en su
materia
ahora los alumnos por otra parte es que
ellos la tienen desde también muy fácil
estar para ellos va a ser muy divertido
estudiar porque lo que tienen que hacer
ellos es completar las tareas en los
ejercicios que ustedes les asignen y
ellos lo van a poder hacer a su propio
ritmo es decir si ustedes desean que lo
usen como tarea lo podrán hacer como
tarea pero también lo podrán hacer en el
salón de clases dependiendo de las
condiciones que tenga su escuela pues
alumnos podrán realizar las actividades
e ir ganando puntos y medallas decisión
limitada dentro del salón clase y fuera
este y el maestro va a tener una cosa
que es un tablero y en ese tablero al
asignar las diferentes tareas él va a
poder ir viendo quién ha ido completando
las tareas y el tablero va a ir subiendo
de nivel cada vez que los alumnos vayan
realizando sus tareas
y al lograr llegar a un cierto nivel
la clase va a poder descargar ciertos
premios virtuales y medallas que el
alumno va a poder ir acumulando en su
perfil y con este entre los premios que
tenemos vamos a tener por un lado para
los profesores una vez que termine el
campeonato los cursos van a tener un
certificado personalizado de khan
academy ellos lo van a poder descargar
desde la plataforma con su nombre ellos
van a poder poner exactamente como
quieren que aparezca su nombre el del
certificado y los alumnos lo que van a
tener y eso es algo que el profesor va a
poner este poner dentro de la plataforma
como una dinámica ese son certificados
personalizables qué quiere decir esto
que si tú tienes un alumno que le echo
muchas ganas y ayuda tal vez a otro
alumno que estaba rezagado pues le
pueden hacer un certificado especial a
ese alumno o si además de diferentes
grupos si pusiste nombre al grupo pues
le vas a poner este
y el como poniendo diferentes nombres a
cada uno entonces vamos a tener también
como parte de las estrategias vamos a
poner una hits especial para la clase en
el cual los profesores van a poder este
que estén participando van a poder
recibir un premio cómo funciona el
campeonato pues muy fácil es si lo
consideramos por etapas lo que tiene que
hacer el profesor en un inicio es
asignar diferentes actividades en khan
academy para fortalecer pues las
diferentes habilidades de la materia de
sus alumnos y una vez que los alumnos
vayan realizando estas actividades pues
van a ir desarrollando mentes más
fuertes y van a poder ellos mismos con
las actividades que vemos que tenemos a
la plataforma desarrollar estrategias de
aprendizaje y con este tablero que les
mencionó en los premios pues van a poder
celebrar el avance y los
esto es un poco una muestra de cómo se
va a ver el tablero pueden ir viendo que
hay estos círculos concéntricos este y
conforme vayan los alumnos ganando
o haciendo las tareas van a ir ganando
estos premios que den aquí y lo que
vamos a sugerir es que al menos por
semana hagan tres actividades por cada
bloque que tengan en su clase no tres
actividades puede ser que lean un
artículo que vean un vídeo o que
realicen una prueba lo que ustedes
quieran con que ellos realicen se va a
ir va a ir subiendo este el tablero y
vayan van a ir avanzando los por los
diferentes niveles del tablero
aquí está por ejemplo un momento de
celebración en el cual toda la clase
pues realizó todas las tareas estos
momentos de celebración van a estar
dentro de la plataforma y como les
comento los profesores que se inscriban
al programa y desean participar vamos a
obtener unas cajas sorpresas que
queremos este pues de cierta manera me
farc para estos profesores que estén
participando y mandárselas a sus
escuelas
el profesor va a tener este tablero y
los alumnos van a tener estos premios
digitales este les voy a mostrar un
poquito como éste este programa ha
suscitado muchísima emoción y mucha
gente en el salón de clases y tenemos
ejemplos de todos los contextos
totalmente distintos
este el de eeuu y el de brasil pero si
se parece mucho a méxico en muchas cosas
y van a ver la alegría y la felicidad de
ver como
lograron sus objetivos como le dan click
al tablero y ver cómo va subiendo y se
vuelven muy felices
sí
mira
bueno hay un momento de felicidad en un
salón de clases
y
[Aplausos]
bueno como pueden ver hasta un abrazo le
tocó a la maestra y queremos que méxico
y los nutrientes en méxico estén igual
de emocionados y felices de ir a
estudiar de hacer más tarea de aprender
porque qué pasa cuando tú estás haciendo
tú te estás avanzando y ves que tú tú
mismo te estás logrando sus objetivos
pues logramos ese nivel de felicidad y
de compromiso de los alumnos
este vamos a seguir adelante
otro tema es súper importante es la de
como contenido que es exclusivo del
programa son las actividades de
mentalidad de crecimiento y estas
actividades las desarrollamos con un
grupo de investigadores de la
universidad de stanford ellos se dedican
a estudiar el rendimiento académico y
cómo la tecnología impacta el
rendimiento académico y también todo el
aspecto psicológico del aprendizaje no
ellos se basaron en el trabajo de una
psicóloga que se llama carol dweck y
ella estudia precisamente el cerebro
lo que se llama mentalidad de
crecimiento este concepto es si lo
podemos resumir de una manera muy rápida
es como todas estas creencias que
tenemos sobre la inteligencia y nuestro
cerebro no tenemos nacemos con ciertas
ideas de a esta persona sugería esta
persona es brillante y no sabemos en
realidad cómo funciona nuestro cerebro
las personas no nacen siendo brillantes
simplemente éste tienen mentalidades
diferentes no entonces lo que hemos
desarrollado son una serie de
actividades para los profesores para que
ayuden a que los estudiantes tengan más
confianza al estar estudiando que les
den y compartan estas estrategias con
sus estudiantes para entender cómo
funciona su cerebro y también pues
darles estas guías a los profesores para
desarrollar mentes fuertes que estén
preparadas para superar la frustración
de no lograr ser un ejercicio bien o
tener múltiples errores al hacerlo
entonces esto va a ser parte del
contenido de el campeonato y los
profesores que asignen estas actividades
pues también van a poder ir seguir este
acumulando puntos y siguiendo en el
tablero
aquí este estamos compartiendo un
testimonio de un de una maestra de
matemáticas del conalep el año pasado
lanzamos un piloto ni siquiera el
producto con el tablero y los premios y
todo todo esto para méxico y esta
maestra para que si pone un piloto con
sus alumnos de matemáticas y se dio
cuenta que sus alumnos venían al
principio antes de hacerle la prueba y
el reto pues medio empáticos no pero a
dice que después de este reto pues los
vio más interesados en aprender
matemáticas
sobre todo porque el contenido mejor os
comentaba pues tiene este está
aterrizado y orientado a la vida de los
estudiantes
entonces los invitamos por favor a que
se inscriban a partir del lunes tenemos
la noticia también de que en eeuu y en
la india también vamos a estar corriendo
el programa es algo muy emocionante
porque por primera vez en méxico y en la
india este programa se va a estar
lanzando y seguro vamos a estar
compartiendo todos estos momentos de
alegría en emoción con los estudiantes
de distintas partes del planeta
este sentimos que es un regreso a clases
muy especial para ustedes y a partir del
10 de septiembre van a poder pues ir
asignando las tareas y viendo cómo va
avanzando este su tablet mano este como
les comentaba pueden inscribirse desde
él
desde ahora desde el 13 de agosto hasta
el 16 de noviembre este y le cedo la
palabra para ti para que pueda
comentarles un poquito pues cómo
comenzar con la plataforma aseguró
muchos tienen la idea de que tal vez sea
algo complicado y queremos esclarecer
cualquier duda que tengan y terminar
este con estas ideas de que estén
participadas
va a ser difícil lo como leamos como
empiezo pues queremos que para ti no
salió precisamente
a ayudarles en todo lo que se pueda en
este webinar
bueno antes que nada antes de pasarnos a
la plataforma digamos sí
quisiera contestar algunas preguntas que
nos han hecho a través del chat me
preguntan ángel rodríguez que qué
innovaciones específicamente tiene la
plataforma de khan academy vienen muchas
innovaciones empezando porque el can
academy tiene una nueva presentación
tenemos nuevo logo etcétera y con ello
vienen también algunos cambios que
todavía no se activan al 100% pero ya
pronto vamos a comenzar a verlos en la
plataforma un cambio importante viene
siendo en la sección de lo que es el
progreso y ahí vienen ya
lo que es este cambios importantes que
nos van a ayudar muchísimo como maestros
no va a tener una información mucho más
detallada de el desempeño de nuestros
alumnos no solamente en una misión si
estamos asignando una misión sino
también en unidades nos estamos
asignando unidades de estudio entonces
vienen cambios muy buenos muy positivos
que ya les platicaremos con más detalle
más adelante también por otro lado me
preguntan
si mar que los grupos son de dos alumnos
se puede participar en el mínimo el
número mínimo de alumnos por clase para
que puedan participar es de 10 deben
tener un mínimo de 10 alumnos en su
clase para poder inscribir a la clase
y le pregunta a mario espinoza que si su
hijo individualmente puede participar
tampoco puede partir se pueden
participar de manera individual tienen
que ser parte de una clase y como repito
el mínimo de alumnos debe ser de 10
ok vamos a
[Música]
a comenzar está ahorita ya directamente
en la plataforma lo que yo voy a hacer
es enseñarles a aquellos que no tienen
todavía una una cuenta con khan academy
entonces vamos a comenzar desde a crear
nuestras cuentas y este si ustedes
tienen su dispositivo a la mano los
invito a que la abran a que abra su
computador su tablet su celular etcétera
para que lo hagan conmigo y terminemos
este webinar ya con una cuenta creada y
aquellos que ya tienen una cuenta que ya
abrieron una cuenta bueno vamos a ver
cómo podemos comenzar a crear nuestras
clases entonces voy a compartir con
ustedes mi pantalla
vais
no quiere esperar un segundito
y aplicase
creo que es esta
ok no quiere me voy porque lo que es que
creo que es esta perdón mil disculpas
para no
ahora sí ya no esté me voy a salir yo
para que vean desde el principio cómo
comenzamos entonces cuando ustedes
entran a ese punto khan academy punto
org esta es el enlace para entrar a la
plataforma de khan academy en español
entonces les pido por favor que vayan a
ese punto
khan academy punto org lo voy a poner en
el chat para que lo tengan ahí más a la
mano
ok entonces
entrará a ese punto khan academy punto
org y van a entrar a esta página
entonces desde aquí voy a crear mi nueva
cuenta entonces como vamos a hacer clic
como maestros otra vamos a entrar como
maestros yo les pido que hagan clic en
maestros inicien aquí
serafín rey los que ya contamos con
cuente con una cuenta les pido que
esperen un momentito nada más para que
los que aquellos que no tienen en cuenta
la puedan crear y ya comenzamos a ver lo
de la creación de clases entonces una
vez que yo hago clic a entrar como
maestro vamos a tenemos tres opciones
entrar con nuestra cuenta de google de
libros entrar con nuestra cuenta de
facebook y registrarnos con nuestro
correo electrónico yo siempre les
sugiero registrarse con su correo
electrónico en primeras si nos
registramos con facebook y luego
cerramos nuestra cuenta o lo que sea
vamos a perder toda nuestra información
de la cuenta o bien pues tampoco
queremos vincular nuestra una clase de
que nuestra cuenta de khan academy que
es profesional a lo mejor con nuestro
facebook que es personal no que entonces
para no hacer esta también conexión
entonces le podía le surgieron
nuevamente registrarse con su correo
electrónico hacen clic ahí y aquí
escriben su correo electrónico
a continuación ponen su nombre su
apellido
y van a poner una contraseña que tenga 8
caracteres
apunte en algún lado para que no se les
olvide olvide y que tengan números
letras y otros caracteres y una vez que
ya tengan su contraseña lista
automáticamente se activa este botón que
dice regístrate entonces una vez que
tienen completa su información le van a
dar clic aquí en regístrate yo no lo voy
a hacer porque yo ya tengo una cuenta
entonces hagan clic en regístrate y los
que ya tienen una cuenta lo que vamos a
hacer es iniciar sesión entonces vamos a
poner
y el correo
con el que nos registramos y vamos a
poner la contraseña
[Música]
para ti creo que no sé de tu pantalla
tampoco si la estoy viendo acá en el
webinar si la estoy viendo
aquí en el webinar se se ve
se acaba de cortar ya regreso es esto de
la tecnología pero a ver déjenme lo
vuelvo a
a ver ahí está ok entonces una vez que
yo ya creo mi cuenta y entró
automáticamente me va a llevar a lo que
es la página principal de mi cuenta de
khan academy ustedes aquí no van a tener
nada porque pues es la primera vez que
entran a khan academy no tiene ninguna
clase creada todas estas son clases que
yo ya he creado entonces vamos a hacer
clic por favor para aquellos que ya
tienen una cuenta les pido por favor que
entren a su cuenta y los que ya crearon
su cuenta también van a esperarse a que
un momentito a que todos entren y de
aquí lo que vamos a hacer es hacer click
en el botón que dice agregar una clase
entonces vamos a hacer clic todos en
agregar una clase y la verdad es que
agregar una clase es muy fácil de hacer
todo lo primero que voy a hacer es
ponerle un nombre a mi clase en este
caso voy a ponerle demo no
entonces le pongo una clase traten de
ser específicos porque luego nos podemos
confundir entre las clases entonces
pueden ponernos sexto de primaria ave o
tercer periodo primer periodo no pero si
sean específicos en el nombre que le
asignan a su clase si ustedes están
trabajando con google classroom desde
aquí pueden importar toda la información
de su google classroom a su cuenta de oa
su clase de khan academy en el caso de
que no sea así entonces vamos a poner de
modo campeonato
ok y le voy a dar en siguiente
ok aquí lo que tengo yo que hacer es
seleccionar qué curso voy a dar en esta
clase entonces como ustedes pueden ver
aquí son varias las opciones que tenemos
ya en nuestra plataforma en español
tenemos matemáticas por tema digamos por
materia o sea como tan matemáticas
elementales que son las básicas tenemos
aritmética o álgebra trigonometría por
temas digamos o bien tenemos también
matemáticas por grado que éstas vendrían
siendo las misiones nos a completar la
misión del primero de secundaria a
completar la misión de sexto de primaria
o de 3º de secundaria la misión lo que
significa es que van a rabanal en el
momento en que yo asignó este contenido
o está este este curso automáticamente
todos los estándares todos los conceptos
que un alumno tiene que aprender por
ejemplo en primero de secundaria
automáticamente se van a sumar a mi
clase no entonces vamos a seleccionar
como ejemplo primero
tenemos biología química física
ingeniería eléctrica en economía de
finanzas micro macroeconomía finanzas
programas de computación ciencias de
computación codificación y pixar
nosotros todos estos cursos también
pueden participar con cualquiera de
ellos si ustedes están dando biología o
química también pueden participar en
campeonato no solamente es para
matemáticas
entonces vamos a seleccionar ya lo que
es mi materia digamos y le doy clic en
siguiente
y aquí viene la parte de invitar a mis
alumnos entonces aquí yo tengo
diferentes maneras de invitar a mis
alumnos puedo decir a invitar como les
decía a importarlos desde google claro
si yo ya estoy trabajando con google
classroom hago clic aquí y conecto hago
clic en conectar con mis cuentas de
google claro me conecto me salen todas
las clases que tengo en google classroom
y selecciono cuál es la que quiero
importar o bien puedo envite invitar a
mis alumnos a través de un correo
electrónico con esto es lo único que
tengo que hacer aquí pongo en el correo
del alumno
y separado por una coma y un espacio
claro que para esta opción por lo más
tenemos que tenerlos los correos
electrónicos de todos nuestros alumnos y
para mí la opción más rápida y más fácil
es a través de un código cada vez que yo
abro una clase en khan academy esa clase
crea se crea un código específico para
esta clase que es el que ven ustedes
aquí entonces a mí este método me gusta
más porque aprovechó tener cuando tengo
a todos mis alumnos en clase y hasta el
primer día de clases a la semana
etcétera y cuando los tengo a todos
justos juntos en el salón de clase no lo
ustedes lo único que hacen es pedirles
que vayan a khan academy punto org
diagonal join
ok hago clic ahí y automáticamente se
abre esta ventana y dice únete a una
clase y lo único que los alumnos tienen
que hacer es colocar o escribir aquí el
código de la clase y decir únete a la
clase y automáticamente ingresa a la
clase es muy sencillo y muy rápido
entonces yo les sugiero la verdad de
manera la manera más fácil y rápida de
agregarlos a su clase es a través del
código también pueden si quieren
imprimir las instrucciones para unirse
para que los chicos se unan a su clase
esto no sale en los formatos de cuatro
los podemos cortar y darle a cada alumno
oa cada dos alumnos un papelito con
nuestro con el código de la clase
incluso pedirlo a la mejor le podemos
dar a cada alumno al pedirlo que lo
peguen en su cuaderno etcétera para que
siempre lo tengan a la mano es el en
caso de que por algún este problema o
situación pierdan sus datos de la clase
y se salgan
y
otra razón por la que yo prefiero este
método es porque en ocasiones también a
mí me sucedió porque yo fui maestra de
matemáticas y ciencias por diez años en
el colegio americano aquí de la ciudad
de mexico y utilizar la cav y desde
siempre no entonces yo lo que lo que me
daba cuenta es que cuando nos invitaba a
través del correo electrónico de verdad
que un mes después lo seguía
persiguiendo para que se sumaran a mi
clase no y siempre como que ya perdí el
correo mismo lo puedes enviar etcétera
entonces es mucho más rápido hacerlo a
través del código una vez que yo ya
invite a mis estudiantes
no le pongo invitar a mis alumnos ok
y punto con xoom.com ok entonces
autómica automáticamente una vez que
invitamos alumnos la clase ya queda
crear entonces lo que sigue ya viene
explorar el contenido de la misión o de
la materia que yo asigne no pues en este
caso yo digo bueno pues quiero explorar
el contenido de primero de secundaria y
ya desde aquí automáticamente me va a
abrir todos los conceptos todos los
requisitos que un alumno tiene que
cubrir en primero de secundaria para
poder pasar con éxito a segundo de
secundaria
recuerden que nuestra plataforma en la
plataforma en español aquí en méxico ya
está alineada a la zet entonces van muy
de la mano no entonces podemos confiar
plenamente en él no en que lo que nos
están mandando es lo que nosotros
necesitamos hacer y cubrir en nuestras
clases y ya de aquí es muy fácil
comenzar a asignar esto ahorita por por
ahora no queremos comenzar en esta parte
porque ya vendrá otra capacitación para
ver como asignó etcétera pero ahorita el
punto importante es que ustedes aprendan
y aprendan a crear su cuenta aprendan a
crear una clase y todas las clases que
ustedes hayan creado o vayan a crear
automáticamente se van a sumar a él al
campeonato me voy a regresar a la
presentación
aquí ustedes tienen también todos los
pasos en la presentación lo que es justo
hábitat vimos no de abrir su cuenta
primero a crear una clase poner el
nombre asignar un tema una materia a
invitar a sus estudiantes y finalmente
ya tienen su clase crear entonces hasta
aquí nos vamos a quedar en esta parte ya
como les decía en otra capacitación
veremos cómo vamos a asignar ya lo
material a nuestros alumnos y bueno
queremos recordarles que el campeonato
empieza el 13 de agosto es recuerden un
programa gratuito no para con el
objetivo puede de hacer algo diferente a
nuestras nuestras clases motivar a
nuestros alumnos bueno sabemos como
maestros de matemáticas que nuestros
alumnos tienen no mucho miedo a las
matemáticas no y generan estas ciudades
muy negativas respecto a esta materia
porque les da miedo porque sienten que
no son buenos para la
porque les da nervio entonces tienden a
bloquearla odiarla ya ya no gustarles y
la verdad es un asunto grave no porque
finalmente las ciencias también están
relacionadas a las matemáticas van de la
mano y finalmente eso lleva a los
alumnos a tratar de evitar no estas
cualquier carrera en el futuro
relacionada con estos temas no entonces
es importante cambiar el switch cambiar
el enfoque que tienen nuestros alumnos
respecto a lo que es matemáticas y
ciencias no y poder desarrollar en ellos
mentes no sólo más seguros pero seguras
pero también mucho más fuertes entonces
una vez que ustedes ya crean sus clases
como como les comentaba automáticamente
y se bueno está quedan inscritas en el
campeonato o si ustedes quieren crear
una nueva clase la crean y les dice
inscríbete al campeonato habita este
botón todavía no les va a aparecer en la
plataforma va a aparecer hasta la
próxima semana no entonces ya muy pronto
estará comenzando el campeonato no
les pedimos que se vayan preparando
vayan pensando en sus clases en alumnos
no en qué clases van a crear en que lo
que van a estar dando el año que entra
qué materias qué clase son las que
ustedes pueden introducir o pueden éste
inscribir en campeonato
entonces recuerden que son tres pasos
muy simples para participar uno crear tu
cuenta en la plataforma de khan academy
ya vimos 12 crear tus clases recuerden
que para a la hora de crear sus clases
necesitamos invitar a un mínimo de 10
alumnos el tercer punto sería asignar ya
contenido que eso lo veremos en otro en
otro webinar y tenemos que asignar un
mínimo de 3 actividades por alumno cada
semana que dure el reto el reto tiene
una duración de 10 semanas entonces
durante cada semana le vamos a asignar
mínimo tres actividades a cada uno de
nuestros alumnos todos los alumnos lo
tienen que completar no para que
realmente la clase o el grupo de
estudiantes pueda ir subiendo no hay
ganando puntos y la tercera el tercer
como otra parte del asignar contenido
viene siendo revisar el tablero de
progreso no para ir celebrando los
logros de los alumnos
de verdad que yo quiero hacer mucho
énfasis en esta parte de la celebración
porque es sumamente importante los
alumnos esta parte de verdad que yo
quiero hacer mucho énfasis en la parte
de la asimilación porque es sumamente
importante
esta parte que
ok algo pasó aquí ver están viendo no
están bien a mí para mí la presentación
verdad
si la vemos
ok
seguimos me escuchan leonor
sí perfecto
me escuchan ahorita
bueno bueno
aunque es que algo algo pasó de repente
como que se apagó todo pero bueno
entonces estos son los tres pasos que
debemos seguir para para participar en
el campeonato
cuáles son las maneras de participar
bueno yo aquí les quería comentar eso no
olvidó juguete perdí aquí el la idea que
hablamos de celebrar los logros de los
alumnos es muy importante esta parte y
ustedes todo conocen a sus alumnos y
dependiendo la personalidad de cada
docente
hay que encontrar maneras de reconocer
el esfuerzo de los alumnos y celebrar
sus logros no se puede ser a través de
diplomas a través de un aplauso a través
de no sé traerles galletas pero ya
dependiendo de la personalidad de cada
uno de ustedes pero si encuentren una
manera y vayan creando un plan de cómo
van a motivar y cómo van a celebrar los
logros de sus alumnos entonces y cómo
vamos a participar nosotros es como les
decía ahorita una parte importante es
celebrar el esfuerzo y el logro el
triunfo de los alumnos no y esto lo va a
ser tanto khan academy como como
plataforma como organización pero
también los invito a ustedes que
hagamos ese pequeño extra esfuerzo para
ustedes también en clase cuando están
con ellos y los motivando y les
reconociendo su esfuerzo
por parte de khan academy habrá premios
semanales para los estudiantes medallas
virtuales certificados pósters etcétera
no la idea también es ir pasando la voz
para para que más gente se una a este
campeonato la verdad es que para nuestro
país es muy importante y debemos
aprovechar nuestra herramienta que es
una plataforma gratis que nos está está
poniendo en nuestras manos
muchos recursos no que tienen un valor
enorme para realmente poder impactar la
forma que estamos enseñando matemáticas
y ciencias en nuestros colegios entonces
compartan la voz comparte los materiales
y recursos con otros profesores inviten
a sus colegas e inviten a sus compañeros
a que se unan a este esfuerzo no a
campeonato y pueden incluso abrirlo como
parte de las estrategias para motivar a
sus alumnos etcétera dentro de la
escuela pueden abrir un club de khan
academy organizar una reunión con los
alumnos del salón de clases durante el
recreo como les digo
por llevar este paletas
galletas o algo donde los alumnos se
sientan que pertenecen a algo no yo creo
que se para todos y todos sabemos que él
está sensación de pertenecer a algo es
muy importante y es muy motivante
entonces si nosotros logramos esto con
los alumnos los alumnos realmente van a
estar como muy conectados con este reto
y van a realmente estar muy
participativos
y bueno también os invitamos a que vayan
a visite www.ubm.com peonato punto org
ahí podrán encontrar también preguntas
frecuentes hasta toda la ayuda de
respuestas a preguntas que puedan tener
y también van a encontrar ahí el
reglamento para para lo que es
campeonato
tenemos aquí algunas preguntas
frecuentes que generalmente nos han
hecho entonces antes de al final vamos a
darles también a ustedes espacio para
que puedan hacerles todas las preguntas
que necesitan entonces qué es el
campeonato y cómo se diferencia de la
plataforma normal de canacar en cómo les
comentamos este campeonato tiene una
duración primero de 10 semanas no es un
programa que está hecho específicamente
para el regreso a clases no para
realmente enganchar a los alumnos
motivarlos a que trabajen dentro de la
plataforma de khan academy que descubran
no lo valioso que puede ser para su
aprendizaje y además del contenido
disponible en la plataforma el maestro
también puede asignar dentro del
campeonato actividades de mentalidad de
crecimiento que son excelentes y digo
sean han sido probadas ya en otras
escuelas y son actividades muy
enriquecedoras y a la vez bueno ir
celebrando el progreso de las clases
todo comprende sus clases con premios
virtuales
especialmente para este programa una vez
que termine campeonato la plataforma
normal va a volver a estar activa como
normalmente no para el resto os
acuérdense recuerden y si no lo saben es
bueno saberlo que khan academy es una
plataforma que funciona en cualquier
lugar durante las 24 horas del día
como pueden partir y participar como
profesor este 10 de septiembre deben
escribir a los alumnos para que
participen en el reto utilicen el
contenido de khan academy recuerden que
khan academy no solamente son vídeos
algunos maestros tienen esta idea de que
solo son vídeos
hoy día hay ejercicios artículos y una
gran variedad de verdad de vídeos ya en
español que pueden asignar a sus alumnos
no recuerden que debemos asignar al
menos tres actividades por alumno por
semana lo cual viene representando entre
20 y 30 minutos de trabajo en la
plataforma por una semana lo cual es
verdaderamente poco no pero no es no
implicar el gran esfuerzo por parte del
alumno y a medida que los estudiantes
completan los ejercicios o tareas
ellos irán progresando a través de los
diferentes niveles niveles de campeonato
y alavés irán recibiendo diferentes
reconocimientos y como estudiantes como
pueden participar pues también
completando las diferentes tareas y
ejercicios que profesó les mande para
poder ir avanzando en los diferentes
niveles y desbloqueando los distintos
premios digitales que pueden recibir
también contestando y resolviendo todas
las actividades de mentalidad de
crecimiento que el maestro así y que se
requiere para pasar de un nivel a otro
como les explicamos khan academy tiene
diferentes perdón campeonato tiene
diferentes niveles el progreso de cada
nivel se completa al asignar tres tareas
por alumno si todos nuestros alumnos
esto es importante recalcar todos
nuestros alumnos de la clase completan
sus tres tareas ellos van van ganando
puntos y subiendo el nivel por ejemplo
una clase con veinte alumnos necesitaría
completar 60 tareas porque son 20 por 3
necesitarían 60 tareas para pasar al
siguiente nivel con un alumno que no las
complete no puede pasar la clase al
siguiente nivel no se requiere y esto es
importante porque finalmente lo que
queremos promover y motivar es la
participación del 100% de los
los que queden inscritos en campeonato
cuánto tiempo debo dedicar al campeonato
en promedio como estamos hablando de que
se van a asignar tres recursos para los
alumnos por semana esto implica más o
menos de 20 a 25 minutos para terminar
cada actividad no entonces se estima que
los alumnos dediquen alrededor de 20 20
25 minutos para terminar cada actividad
o cada bloque de actividad están
dependiendo de las actividades que el
docente está enviando y como profesor
recibiré algún reconocimiento también
los profesores que completen todas las
metas con sus clases podrán solicitar un
certificado de reconocimiento
personalizado hecho especialmente para
este programa
esta pregunta es muy importante porque
puede ser que comience campeonato y
ustedes crean apenas una clase tenemos
nuevos alumnos que se suman a la clase
este programa tendrá una duración de 10
semanas y dentro de las cuales podrán
aprovechar la plataforma las
inscripciones se van a quedar abiertas
para que cualquier profesor profesor se
una a campeonato y pueda participar en
campeonato en cualquier momento dentro
de esas 10 semanas
y todo lo que asigna el profesor cuentas
y todo lo que ustedes asignen a sus
estudiantes durante estas 10 semanas
cuenta si incluso yo asignó más de tres
actividades sea la mejor asignó dos
actividades en todas mis clases etcétera
todo lo que ustedes hagan va a contar
dentro no para campeonato no dentro de
estas diez semanas incluyendo contenido
de otro grado en materia también puedo
puede ser que yo esté hace una de
biología también etcétera o de otra
materia y todo esto cuenta las
actividades que están completadas
cuentan sin importar el grado o si se
entregó tarde esa parte no la estamos
considerando el profesor necesita
asignar las actividades de la mentalidad
de crecimiento para participar si esta
parte es muy importante las actividades
de mentalidad de crecimiento deben ser
asignadas para que realmente la
plataforma pueda tomar en cuenta el
progreso si los estudiantes se adelantan
y completan una actividad de mentalidad
de crecimiento por su cuenta
desde que puso la signo el profesor
tendrá que reasignar la actividad al
estudiante sin embargo el estudiante va
a recibir el crédito dando clic a la
actividad no la va a tener que volver a
realizar porque ya la realizó entonces
el profesor asigna pero el alumno ya
tiene el crédito porque ya completó la
la actividad
qué pasará cuando termine el campeonato
como les comentaba una vez que termine
este programa los profesores y los
alumnos tendrán acceso a la plataforma
ya normal de khan academy no que incluye
las herramientas de tareas todos los
contenidos disponibles los vídeos los
artículos los ejercicios y toda la
plataforma para poderle dar el
seguimiento en el conociendo el progreso
a nuestros alumnos y tener acceso a
todos los diferentes reportes que khan
academy nos ofrece no entonces el
tablero que es una parte esencial para
campeonato ese será removido al igual
que todos los premios digitales creados
para este programa también serán
removidos una vez que termine campeonato
entonces como último pues nos queda
invitarlos a participar que corran la
voz de verdad como les comentaba hace
rato es algo muy importante para nuestro
país para nuestras escuelas para
nuestros niños para realmente ayudarlos
a cambiar está este sentimiento que
tienen hacia las ciencias hasta las
matemáticas y poderles dar las
herramientas no no para que puedan pues
superar los obstáculos que a veces se
les presentan con estas materias y que
cambien la visión que tienen no sobre
matemáticas de ciencias para que puedan
realmente encontrar el gusto y aprender
de no de una mejor manera
entonces para registrarse les vamos a
pedir por por favor que se registren en
este formulario para recibir información
sobre el programa si tienen ahorita su
celular etcétera y no no tienen su
computador les podemos invitar a que le
tomen una foto a esta pantalla para que
ya con calma y después puedan ingresar a
canadá de mi punto tal forma
diagonal t o diagonal z 4 l x o y
complete en el formulario para que
puedan recibir más información si el
olor no sea nada más un pequeño
paréntesis este formulario lo hicimos
porque las inscripciones se abren el 13
de agosto y ahorita si el profesor se
quiere inscribir y quiere empezar a
crear sus clases y agregar a sus alumnos
si lo voy a hacer bueno de hecho puede
registrarse desde ahora pero para
inscribirse al campeonato pues no lo va
a poder hacer hasta el 13 de agosto es
decir hasta el lunes
y algunos este ya desean como recibir
los correos del campeonato y que los
pongamos en nuestra lista pues pueden
llenar el formulario verdad pero si si
quieren esperar lunes también lo pueden
hacer
presente alguna pregunta que esté
pendiente de honor
usted no nos está preguntando juan
carlos que si puede obtener la
presentación lo que vamos a hacer con
carlos es que la voy a poner como parte
de la descripción de este webinar te
parece y no le va a poder dar click y la
va a poder ver entonces cualquier duda
que tenga pues va a poder revisar la
presentación de aceta y verlas las veces
que quieran y compartirla con sus
compañeros si lo desee
ok perfecto
entonces bueno pues si no hay otras
preguntas
que tenemos aquí nos enviarán las listas
de asistencia de este webinar cuando
leonor
como es un evento en línea no tenemos
ese tipo de
pero con mucho gusto les compartimos la
presentación tú tú lo vas a compartir en
algún correo o quieres que compartamos
ahora cuál es la visión de este webinar
cuando tú le das click a la de que dice
khan academy donde dice invitamos a los
profesores de méxico en la descripción
del vídeo voy a poner la liga a la
presentación
yo perfecto pues entonces van a tener
acceso a la presentación y pues por mi
parte y por parte del honores es todo
pero quedamos a sus órdenes para
cualquier duda pregunta o comentario que
quieran hacerlos yo no olvides agregar
algo
nada que estoy muy contenta de que hayan
venido a escucharnos que nos hayan dado
su tiempo sabemos que tienen muchas
cosas que hacer y la verdad lo que
queremos es emocionar lo para este
regreso es entonces los invitamos a
participar muchísimas gracias a todos
los que estuvieron preparadas y no
preguntas que como crea mi clase y como
veo a mis alumnos eso nos da muchísima
alegría extender que los maestros están
emocionados entonces van a ver les va a
ir increíble este y vamos a tener varios
webinars entonces éste no se preocupen
vamos a tener uno específico de canacar
en mi que habla del contenido que es un
menor como nos gustan los artículos como
están configurados y contenido y todo
eso es el próximo webinar el próximo
jueves entonces si se quedaron con dudas
de cómo funciona la plataforma justo
vamos a hablar de eso entonces ustedes
tranquilos
les mando un gran saludo a toda la
república mexicana son nuestros héroes
os queremos mucho
muchas gracias por sintonizarnos hasta
luego a todos
chao